we get to talk to you now that RR is
officially an Oscar winner how does that
feel it feels great it feels amazing
yeah as I said it's just not our win
it's the whole country's been feels
amazing what do you think the country is
saying and thinking and feeling right
now country is saying not to not to
sorry
[Applause]
has to win
pride of every Indian
that performance I mean it was really
good I mean
you know these guys were so good
these guys were so amazing of the moves
were basically all Indian but the way
they pulled it off it was amazing were
you emotional when they announced that
RR had won
yes right yeah I have a rolling tiger so
I was roaring as well
of it
[Music]